[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
real quick before we start this video if
you're here looking for the joke World
comedy news update we'll be back again
next Monday January 2nd thank you so
much for watching this video and have a
happy holiday
Merry Christmas it's our holiday
Extravaganza episode
um I of course celebrate Kwanzaa but for
today I'm making uh an exception and we
have all of this I am Jewish I'm Jewish
and Muslim but for this uh for today uh
assalamu alaikum and and uh whatever
Jews do handy one chalk about to one guy
found somebody else like hey mushroom
chocolates sure then to a third guy and
then one of May's friends say oh no no
break it up pieces yeah I'm already on
mushrooms why did your hand why don't
you give me this responsibility for the
shaman I guess so but [ __ ] talk to me
you are kind of weirdly trustworthy with
[ __ ] like that as I'm
19.20 times the perfect doser yeah yeah
well the 20s was burnt yeah
and I will say I got the right amount in
them
I saw bird then I can vouch she had a
[ __ ] ball dude I did sober October
and I never felt less anxiety really I
was like dude I'm free I thought it was
the weed I talked to Bert though and he
was like no I'm I don't I feel nothing
too it might be the Boost oh booze is
bad this is great who would have thought
that alcohol is birch problem that's
crazy I thought it was sure
oh look at my mouth
oh my god do you gag yes every day so
does my little brother
My grandmother used to do that loves you
my little brother loves you
[Music]
how come
[Music]
listen my grandmother once was eating
asparagus oh my God that [ __ ] [ __ ]
foreign
have you tried
go
a dating app that that's only for little
people that's a good question that
that's a good question good question I
have not tried it but there is one
what's it called hold on hold on hold on
let's go give us a chance
give us a chance over there yeah yeah
all the moment he was like I don't know
I don't know if it's still there I got
one okay okay fumble
laughs
oh my God
Bobby I take back every bad thing I've
ever said about you that was the
funniest thing I've ever heard in my
life oh my God if fumble
if that's not a publicly traded company
soon
fumble is so good Bob that's so great
wow fumble all right Rudy go ahead more
questions for Brad I know you've got him
lined up okay do you
poo every day
yeah
I don't know wait how do you think we
got these things in here
[Laughter]
Reese's Pieces
yeah what the [ __ ] do you think these
things came from the North Pole you
[ __ ] idiot think about that question
right she equates the size with three
music poo every day yeah Orange Theory
great workout classic what is it your
heart rate they go you're [ __ ] for
females dude I got the chicks that are
trying to get husbands you went to a
girl gym like a [ __ ] yeah you're
already married and you're not a lady
like you sit on like a [ __ ] little
bouncy thing and just [ __ ] works yeah
they do it for hot chicks it really is
what bouncy thing it's like a medicine
ball to make your [ __ ] again did you
do the kegels yes you're in Scientology
of gyms yeah dude it is a little culty
Joe's on his back tightening his [ __ ]
holding on the two Soup cans are you
sure no sorry about my health no we're
taking action now you're talking about
your [ __ ] Garfield yeah all right
first of all it's hot chicks you guys
like the guys that make fun of the male
cheerleaders who are just looking up
skirts all day yeah
they have to put Vicks under their nose
so they don't throw up
they're not turned on they're like ew
yeah they go oh my God how does that
have nothing in there no nothing oh
that's it that's like it's a whole
philosophically does it make sense no it
looks like a Muppet's mouth just
sweating and then some hot girls [ __ ]
running listening to a podcast goes my
podcast my [ __ ] cholesterol is high
and she's like get away from me what is
Orange Theory what are you doing I've
always seen it and I thought it was a
[ __ ] uh yogurt shop I thought oh yeah
I thought it was juice you get juice
Julius you dumbed up I thought it's how
they rehabbed like uh paralyzed people
yeah
I thought they put you in a machine
where they move your arm and [ __ ] what's
the theory well tell us the theory all
right so the theory is your heart rate
Joe is gay Joe is gay
jokes does it work as well yeah let's
just make people make their own
assumptions fair enough fair enough Hey
listen no I'm not I'm not a chant guy
I'm not yeah yeah I'm also not above
putting a little pee pee of course I've
got that jacket from one of those guys
okay so you're at the theater right now
Orange Theory
this is the kind of thing Lewis shits on
and then next time you see him he's like
dude I'm telling you Orange Theory I do
it twice a day everything I did before
is stupid this you're not gonna skank
first next year now why we didn't know
he laughed right in my face dude it's
over he can laugh announce the new dates
today he can laugh Orange Theory yeah
it's getting the heart rate into a good
orange Zone
that you usually we talk about that
since the 80s I think this is a new
thing yeah no it's not it's good at your
heart rate of a place you could normally
only get a tooth through butt sex
he's never been here for this and he's
ruined us
because your new gay gym is not going
over well yeah by the way Louis is like
oh you think that's new what do you
think jiu jitsu's New you [ __ ] face hey
you guys you see my new theory of jiu
jitsues hey Lewis you should check out
my new gym it's called jogging mysticism
this thing they've learned where you're
not really running you're just jogging a
little bit it's really good for your
heart rate yeah nice antlers you queer
dude I just I just went to my new gym
it's called dumbbell mythology oh my God
Steam
yeah they had called Orange Theory
because bath house is illegal
well whatever at least I'm not on
prescription meds
what is this you don't want to hear it
I want to go to Orange Theory that
sounds great
picture from the producers
as we talk about things Nicole bring
them up it's just Tom Segura dead or
seriously oh he did die he died at
Orange Theory no anyway the point is to
get splat points
Joe's getting it in the mouth today oh
my god oh guys look who's here to work
out it's our little Splat piggy
Joseph's flat piggy I called dibs on
Joe's mouth that makes my penis look
bigger
Christmas is a little more than a week
away and I can imagine you're a little
stress my arms are tired
but I can imagine you're a little
stressed yes what's that like is that
why you're behaving the way I mean the
energy on you right now is is palpable
yes I I get what what the doctor calls
uh HPV tension headaches
well you get uh when you get overwhelmed
I mean trying to be the guy I imagine
what Michael Jordan felt in game
anything of any finals ever you got me I
once uh when I was a boy I asked for a
action figure or a toy or doll of
Michael Jordan and this is are you
showing the movie rights to the story
this is what you brought me
Jordan brought you that you when I was a
kid I asked don't expect me to remember
every [ __ ] doll I break I'm telling
you I asked for a Michael Jordan doll
and you gave me this well that's the
closest thing we had in stock because
there but then how come the next year
you got me this well I was
overcompensating
Christmas Eve I got planned at my
sister's house that party has moved to
my sister's house nice from from
Denise's to my sisters
um she's gonna cook and that's a good
time over there it's trashy we've gotten
into those Tick Tock games Tick Tock the
kids like playing The Tick Tock games
it's like uh the first time so they have
like a big counter similar like my Mom's
Kitchen like the big like yeah
and you take always a sign of a rich kid
ladies and gentlemen in the 80s and 90s
sure when they had when they had the
island it's went back that's what that's
that's back when it Ryan's on a couple
of bucks rolling around I used to look
under those look at those islands and be
like man yeah must be nice sure and then
your family breaks up and it's not that
nice
given anything for one Christmas all
right
two Christmases and everything that's
cracked up to be
how about one loving family how about
that one two three jingle bells jingle
bells jingle all the way
oh what fun it is
you're improvising I don't like it you
don't want the improvisation
no merry Christmas happy Hanukkah happy
Kwanzaa happy Festivus happy happy happy
the Satan worshipers have a thing or no
better believe it happy Satan day is
that what it is yeah because they think
Satan was the one that um killed Jesus
but if Jesus was born on the 25th if if
oh whoa
whoa whoa oh my bad yeah yeah presumably
he was he was maybe yeah I wasn't there
how would I know I wasn't at the manger
in a way we were all there whoa let's
see the birth certificate let's shop
right just like Obama
foreign
[Music]